hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor make sure that you subscribe
for more free biology study videos and
please make sure you check out
the link in the description that will
take you to
a folder where you can get
a lot of free study notes so these are
pdfs
basically all of my board pictures so
i'll have a picture of this whole board
with all of my notes and all of the
correct answers written in and you can
get those for free at the link below
now let's go ahead and get started
today's topic is passive immunity
and this includes passive inoculation
some people have a tendency to use these
terms interchangeably and they are
related but not interchangeable so keep
an eye out and i'll show you how to
different
before we jump into talking about
passive immunity i really want to talk
about active immunity for just a second
to make sure you understand the
distinction
so this first point is about active
immunity now active immunity is when an
immune system
develops a natural immune response
to an antigen that has entered the body
such as during an infection
so
this um this active immunity is what you
typically think of
when you think about just a natural
immune response when someone is infected
with some kind of pathogen
so it results in full immunity that
means you've got you know b cells and
you've got t cells you've got antibodies
you've got memory b cells and memory t
cells just that full
robust immune response
so now let's talk about how passive
immunity is different
passive
immunity
occurs when an ant when an individual
receives
antibodies
from another individual so whereas
active immunity is when someone is
making their own immune response
including their own antibodies
passive immunity is when an individual
receives antibodies from another
individual now i do have another video
on antibody structure and function so if
you want to learn more about antibodies
what they look like how they work check
that one out
so passive immunity an individual
receiving antibodies from another
individual rather than making their own
now this results in some protection yes
somebody receiving antibodies from
another person those antibodies can then
help defend that person against a
specific pathogen but
there's no
memory here
now
technically
antibodies we typically associate those
with immune system memory and that when
an immune system recognizes a pathogen
basically recognizes an antigen from a
pathogen that it's seen before
it will start producing antibodies as
well as other immune defenses against
that pathogen
so the person
you know the other individual
whose immune system made these
antibodies that is based on immune
memory
but the person who receives the
antibodies they just receive these
antibodies and their own immune system
will not um
gain any kind of memory to the pathogen
the way they would in an actual
infection
now there's two kinds of passive
immunity there is natural passive
immunity
and artificial passive immunity i do
have a diagram over here showing that
how you've got immunity adaptive
immunity artificial versus natural and
within each of these you've got active
versus passive and we'll talk about
specific examples here at the end
but looking just at the natural and the
artificial
talking basically about this one right
here the second one and this fourth one
those are our passive immunities
with natural passive immunity
this is when
antibodies are passed from a mother to
her offspring
via either the placenta
remember the placenta is an
organ
that is grown during childbirth or not
during childbirth during um pregnancy
during that early development
in the uterus
for
basically um
nutrients to be given to the growing
baby
so
igg
or immunoglobulin g is the type of
antibody that a mother will pass to her
baby via the placenta
another way that a mother can pass
antibodies basically share antibodies
with her offspring
is via
breast milk
when she is feeding her baby and that's
going to be
iga or immunoglobulin a again if you're
not familiar with igg or iga or the
other types of antibodies check out my
video on antibody structure and function
just for some more detail there
but so this is called natural passive
immunity because it's a very natural
process right every person who's ever
been born
has received antibodies from their
mother when they were in their mother's
uterus
any child who has been breastfed will
have received
antibodies from their mother during the
the act of breastfeeding so that's the
natural passive immunity and now we can
talk about the second type that's the
artificial passive immunity artificial
passive immunity is when antibodies
that are typically produced in a
laboratory
are injected into an individual
to prevent or fight a specific infection
now this is also known as passive
inoculation
now i said at the beginning passive
immunity and passive inoculation are not
interchangeable terms
passive inoculation is another word for
this artificial passive immunity so it's
one type of passive immunity
now here before we move on i want to
make a couple of points clear
one
is that the artificial
passive immunity has to do with passing
antibodies from one individual to
another
in a way that involves some kind of
medical procedure basically
so the antibodies can either be produced
in a laboratory or i should have written
this on the board also i'll i'll write
it right here produced in a laboratory
or
um
[Music]
donated
as plasma
so if you've heard of someone donating
blood um you can also donate plasma
during the covid19 pandemic i think
we've heard a lot about convalescent
plasma and that's plasma
donated by a person who had previously
had cova 19 and had fought off that
infection and so would have antibodies
in their blood that they could donate
so the antibodies here they're either
the ones that are going to be donated
that's the convalescent plasma or
produced in a laboratory another major
treatment for covid19 especially later
in the pandemic has been with specific
monoclonal antibodies i'm going to put
that in parentheses here so this would
be the kind that's produced in a
laboratory monoclonal
antibodies
but either way whether i know people
personally in my life who received
convalescent plasma when they were
hospitalized with covet 19 from from a
donor
and i know people who received a
monoclonal antibody treatment
in the hospital when they were sick with
probit 19 later
later in the pandemic so all both of
those are types of artificial passive
immunity so it's where you have
antibodies that were either produced in
a lab or donated by just some donor out
there that are then
injected and really the method here when
i say injected i don't mean like an
intramuscular shot i mean this is an iv
administration so administered
intravenously
right into like a vein
um so an iv
administration of these antibodies into
an individual either to prevent right it
could be like a prophylactic treatment
so to prevent them from contracting a
certain disease perhaps
just for example if you if somebody was
exposed to a person who is ill they
might be administered
um like monoclonal antibodies
prophylactically so to prevent a disease
or to fight off a specific infection if
they had already tested positive for it
and so that is the passive inoculation
part
now in either form of passive immunity
so either
natural or artificial
the transferred antibodies whether it's
coming from a mother to her offspring
via placenta or breast milk or whether
it was an intravenous administration of
monoclonal antibodies or convulsive
plasma either way
antibodies have a half-life they don't
last forever
and so
those transferred antibodies
will be
to get kind of low here
degraded
okay will be degraded over time
so degraded over time um typically this
is several months you know three to six
months
kind of depends but um basically once
the antibodies have been
received
um they they only last
several months and once that time
has passed they will have been degraded
and that immunity that passive immunity
will have been
eliminated unless more antibodies are
transferred
[Music]
so passive immunity tends to be
transient whereas active immunity this
full immune response particularly
because it's got the memory cells it can
last decades last an entire lifetime
because there are those memory cells
ready and waiting to recognize that
pathogen again and to mount an immune
response if it comes
so
now let's take a look at this diagram
we've got the innate and adaptive arms
of immunity
within the adaptive arm there's the
artificial and the natural like we've
been talking about and for both
artificial and natural we have active
and passive components i'm just going to
summarize those here
artificial
active
this is going to generate memory and
this is what would happen
for example from a vaccine
so a vaccine is artificial in the sense
that it's not like a natural infection
but it's very active so it's going to
result in full immunity you know a
person who gets a vaccine
is going to have b cells and t cells and
antibodies and memory cells to
to fight off the pathogen and to
remember it in the future
so that's the that artificial active
component and yes there's memory with
that
the artificial
passive component is like what we were
talking about right here so this is
where you've got like convalescent
plasma or i'm actually going to write
just as the example here
monoclonal antibodies
there's no memory
but it can be a good way to increase
immunity for a temporary amount of time
so that's the artificial passive looking
at the natural end of things the active
natural situation that results in memory
this would be
such as during an infection so just like
your regular garden variety infection a
person
contracts an infection they are
colonized by a pathogen their immune
system
naturally mounts this active memory
response to an infection
and then finally that natural passive
uh
immune response with no memory this is
where i'm going to write maternal
antibodies
so maternal antibodies again it's kind
of a short term
transient sort of protection that can
last you know a few to several months
just until that baby's immune system has
matured and it's making a lot of its own
antibodies you know
several months after after birth and
after breastfeeding has concluded
so that brings us to the end for passive
immunity and passive inoculation thank
you for watching make sure you go down
to that link to get the free study notes
make sure you subscribe and i will see
you next time good luck with all of your
studying bye